the Joe Rogan experience right and what
was the motivation behind starting your
podcast
it's called mindscape mindscape yeah
mindscape um yeah I've been having lots
of fun with the podcast it's been great
and several episodes about quantum
mechanics most recently just last week I
did a whole two hour solo episode on how
space-time can emerge from quantum
mechanics the I'll tell you the
motivation was when I wrote my previous
book the big picture it was a sprawling
book so it's not only physics but also
philosophy and neuroscience and biology
and math and computer science there's a
whole bunch of things in there that I'm
not an expert on I'm a big believer that
people should talk about things they're
not an expert on but they should talk
about them in some sense of humility
that I don't understand everything here
so I will talk to some experts right so
I went around talking to experts I you
know I I interviewed people it's so much
fun because I was writing a book I could
literally just email a Nobel
prize-winning biologist and say could I
drop by and talk to you for an hour and
they would say yes and when the book was
done that went away I can't I can't I
don't have license to just call people
up randomly it's like if I talk to you
for an hour
that'll podcast and suddenly you know
people want to talk to you right so yeah
I've gotten you know I talked to Wynton
Marsalis
the trumpet player right you know the
grammy-winning trumpet player I talked
to Seth MacFarland
the other day I puck Nobel Prize winners
MacArthur prize winners philosophers
biologists documentary filmmakers it's I
just really have a blast
so yeah this podcasting thing I think
it's gonna take off you should look into
it
yeah it's well for me I mean there's no
way I would be able to get someone like
you to sit down explain things like this
without a podcast well it is a it's
taking advantage I think right I mean
I'm not telling you this let's say we're
telling the audience this but it's it's
your we can talk as long as we want
right like you take advantage of this
better than anybody and it's different
it doesn't replace things like books
okay but like books are always where you
can get into the weeds a little bit
maybe a little bit more specific a
little bit more careful but there's a
long road you know
there's a lot of books out there I'm not
gonna read all of them that was the
other motivation behind starting my own
podcast is that I had a stack of books I
wanted to read and to force myself to
read them I would invite the author onto
the podcast but I can't read all those
books which books should I read
you know there's there's a whole you
know journey to saying oh like this is
important enough I should dedicate
myself to you know a week of my time to
reading this book and hearing people
talk about it in an informal setting is
you know both illuminating but also like
oh yeah there's ideas in there I really
need to get to so I'm a big believer in
diverse ecosystems I like Twitter I like
little YouTube videos I like podcasts I
like books I like talks there's all
sorts of ways to get this information
yeah I think it's opened up the interest
in a far broader group of human beings
too because and having conversations
like this with you or with you know the
hundreds of people that I get to talk to
in a regular basis it sparks ideas in
people that you know in their seemingly
mundane existence maybe just wouldn't
ever get in there and it allows these
new areas of inquiry in the new areas
for them personally to go look into and
I get messages and meet people all the
time they tell me how much it's changed
the way they view things because they've
now been exposed to interesting
information that's sort of sparked their
their their view of the world in a
different way ignite at different parts
of their imagination and absolutely and
including me like literally yesterday
one of the areas that I had hoped to get
onto mindscape podcast is economic some
very interesting economics but I
realized I don't know crap about
economics like I'm not interested in you
know the trade deal or what interest
rate the Fed should set and the problem
in economics is it's too relevant to the
real world so people want to talk about
you know monetary policy and things like
that but I want to talk about the
underlying theoretical ideas right and I
realized I just it's hard to get those
so I downloaded some economics podcasts
so I started listening them and this
happens to me all the time when this new
good podcast I'm in the car and I have
to stop it to think about what just
happened because
they gave me they said something and it
gave me an idea and the great thing
about being a physicist is there's some
relationship between what I do for a
living and almost everything else right
like whether it's economics or biology
or philosophy so I can always say like
hmm that's an interesting idea I wonder
if I should you know write a paper about
that so and I wouldn't have done that
very easily without the podcast format
you know no it's a really interesting
time it's a really exciting time to
spread information it's a really
exciting time to find things that you're
interested in yeah and also you know I
always noticed this about the internet
in general which is that it calls you on
your crap a little bit right like before
the Internet you know you could have
opinions about things and you could
spout off to your friends and you know
over the dinner table or whatever over
drinks and suddenly when I started
having a blog and I would spout off and
people would say like yeah you're full
of [ __ ] like what are you talking about
I think you say that you know sit back
and think like oh maybe I am full of
[ __ ] like where did I get that idea
right yeah and I think that despite all
the misinformation etc that's out there
if you are intellectually responsible
and want to get things right putting
your ideas out there in public to be
critiqued is a wonderful tool it really
does oh yeah so like it helps you figure
out like what I do understand and know
and what just were kind of vague ideas
that somehow got into my brain for no
good reason
yeah if you're open to the the
floodgates that's the problem is there's
so much feedback that's it's really hard
to separate the wheat and the chaff it
is yeah and you know different people
have different strategies like when I
talked to Seth MacFarlane he it was it
was interesting he reads the comments
like he wants to know we have like 12
million he and he hates it he's like
it's poisonous and toxic and but he
reads that and and and you know for good
reasons he's like look I'm creating
entertainment like if I don't know what
the people I'm trying to reach think
about it what is the point it's like
much like me and physics like the kind
of physics I do is not building a better
machine or curing cancer right it's only
because human curiosity leads us there
so if I don't tell other people about it
what's the point and
but we did have a conversation about
blocking people on Twitter because I was
like the only reason why I like Twitter
is good I block everyone who is a jerk
you know like if they make my Twitter
experience less pleasant they get
blocked right away
yeah that's a good move yeah there's a
lot of loud noise and there's a lot of
wonderful people that met wonderful
people like half of my podcast guests
come because I you know got to know
their Twitter feeds and yeah yeah yeah
I've read a lot of other people's things
I don't read any of my stuff like any of
the stuff that's coming at me it just it
got too overwhelming after a while it
also it interferes with the time that
you have to put stuff out because people
get wrapped up in responding to their
mentions or reading their matches and
there's an extraordinary amount of time
that you can waste doing that yeah I
mean that's the secret like people ask
like you know how can I spend so much
time on Twitter and like what are you
talking about like I spend five minutes
a day on Twitter yeah tweeting and maybe
another 15 minutes reading other
people's tweets and zero-time responding
to tweets that's the secret like if you
yes Twitter is a terrible medium for
conversing right you just can't be
precise you can easily misunderstand yes
and people easily become aggressive
jerks right it's the worst possible way
to have a back-and-forth unless you
already know somebody and are just
trying to clarify something so I use it
for linking to things like I say twitter
is for linking up for thinking it's yeah
it's like the hierarchy of communication
top of the food chain is one-on-one
talking just two people having a
conversation and especially without any
sort of heightened sense of importance
or anger or frustration with that other
person just two people talking that's
number one like to do with no gravity
right number two is probably phone calls
like calling someone they don't see them
it's not as good you know but like being
in front of someone physically
one-to-one is the best way to do it
which is one of the reasons why I love
podcasts as well is because you get a
chance to put that energy out there the
energy of a one-on-one actual
conversation with people as opposed to
writing an article like you know I'm
sure you've had snarky articles written
about you it's it's weird it's like well
that I wouldn't say that
why are you saying it that well you
determine my thoughts and and I've
almost gotten to the point where I never
respond to those not get a lot of I mean
I got a lot of them
[Applause]